we have some of the other names now that
have been confirmed by their by their
families actually um the children who
died amory joe garza her death confirmed
by her
father on on facebook and javier lopez
whose mother actually had been at the
school earlier in the day for an awards
ceremony and later found out that he had
died eva morales we mentioned that the
teacher who died irma garcia as well the
other
teacher believed to have lost her life
and the investigation continues here on
the ground i mentioned the huge amounts
of police activity that continues here
the police particularly looking into the
motive of the the gunman they say they
don't have that as yet they know that um
he began this by shooting his
grandmother drove then to the school
crashed his car into the school gates
and then entered the school and and
carried out the shooting he was actually
stopped by a border patrol agent who saw
what was going on we're quite close to
the u.s mexico border here saw what was
going on didn't wait for backup went
into the school and shot dead
the gunman uh we know that on social
media he had been hinting about uh some
kind of attack in messages to other
people he had put pictures of those
rifles which the police say he bought on
his 18th birthday two assault rifles he
bought on his 18th birthday he posted
pictures of those rifles but they will
look into his uh his background of what
possible motivation there could have
been
for this incident as this town and
america continues to mourn